good morning John my life this week has
been dictated by natural phenomena as
Montana has continued through an
unseasonable hot and dry summer my
Valley has been socked with smoke
sometimes enough that experts advised me
not to leave my house
certainly not with an infant and that
got substantially worse when the nearest
fire in Lolo National Forest have flared
and burned more than 9,000 acres in one
evening
it was beautiful though I was headed out
to get dinner for Catherine and I didn't
come home for an hour because I kept
stopping to film it and then of course
this Monday there was the Eclipse and
one of the remarkable things about the
Eclipse is that we knew exactly when it
was going to happen for decades in
advance we had enough lead time to get a
bunch of Eclipse glasses made and sent
the gas stations all over the country
people booked hotel rooms and braved
terrible traffic though not before first
making sure that the Sun would be out in
the place where they were going and we
trusted all of those things I couldn't
tell you how people figured out when
eclipses were gonna show up before
computers but they did it I also don't
know how scientists fight fires or
predict them or no to tell me when I
shouldn't go outside to avoid damaging
my lungs but I do know that someone
knows someone knows when the eclipse
will happen someone knows when fires
will probably get worse and they've had
their work checked by other people who
also know I don't have the space in my
head to figure all these things out on
my own and like good thing because the
story of human progress is not a story
of every single person figuring out
every single thing for themselves John
when telling people that I trust experts
I sometimes hear people respond that I'm
committing a logical fallacy appealing
to Authority and this is a fallacy when
making an argument saying but this
expert says so is not a good argument
but I'm not actually making an appeal to
one person I'm making an appeal to a
process that has had a good deal of
success at accurately explaining and
predicting stuff the expert is the proxy
for the process I'm making an appeal not
just to the people who have figured
something out but to all of the other
people who I know are gonna check their
work I'm making an appeal to statistics
and logic in calculus and peer review
I'm making an appeal to science and also
I'm often not making an argument I'm not
trying to convince people of what they
should believe I'm trying to explain
that when it comes to things that I'm
not that interested in or capable of
learning enough about I'm happy to
accept scientific
census because it's gonna be a whole lot
better than whatever hunch I happen to
have this isn't trusting that they're
right it's accepting that people who
study things for a living have a far
greater chance of being right than
someone who just feels like arguing with
them it's not an appeal to Authority is
I can appeal to sanity I get worried
about the current tendency of some to
feel like they must confirm everything
for themselves
that's individualism taken to maybe a
fatal extreme human progress is a story
of building on the work of others not
every single person starting from
scratch I agree that trusting
individuals because they've had the
expert label applied to them can lead to
trouble but one of the great
achievements of our culture of our
society is the creation and refinement
of robust systems for creating and
identifying trustable expertise of
course those systems can always be
refined and improved but those who think
they can just be discarded scare me
watching these beautiful and terrible
plumes of smoke flare above my town I
felt very grateful to those who study
these things for a living so I do not
have to John I'll see you on Tuesday
endscreen John happy 40th birthday
yesterday we made you a bunch of turtle
cakes I hope that you liked them there's
so many turtle cakes also Ralph the dumb
party game that dftba games is making
its kickstarter is ending in just a few
days so if you want to help that out and
pledge to get a copy there's a link in
the description also to everybody on the
Gulf Coast of Texas and Louisiana
hopefully won't be as bad as it looks
like it might be but be safe make good
decisions thinking about you